welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the old guard on netflix is one
piece of actually new content allowing
us to escape from our dark reality
and to even darker fiction where death
is wished for both for oneself
and for dudley dursley
i'm gonna break down all the interesting
visual details you might have missed in
this
connections to the graphic novel series
it's based on and the insane history and
mythology of these immortals
spoiler warning if you haven't yet taken
a break between episodes of flores lava
to give into netflix's other pushy
recommendation i get it i'm also weirded
out by them not coming back up from that
lava where do they go
netflix 2020 where school teachers drown
in kool-aid yet charlize theron comes
back after a shot to the face
let us start with the opening scene i've
been here before
over and over again and each time the
same question
is this it charlize throne plays andy
leader of a group of immortal
mercenaries called the old guard
her full name is andromeda cythian and
andromache is over 6 700 years old she
emerged in the 5th millennium bc
her name dates back to greek mythology
an amazon queen who fought heracles also
the name of hector's wife during the
trojan war this edramaki is hinted to be
all of these women and now the scythians
were a nomadic tribe roaming around the
area of modern day ukraine and southern
russia known for its female warriors and
their horsemanship andy may have just
like picked up all of these titles over
her thousands of years of existence her
team includes
joe aka yusuf al-kassani a merchant son
of magrib
who during the crusades in 1099 clashed
with nikki niccolo of genoa and the two
became lovers
and then there's booker sebastian
leliever whom they found in 1812 during
the napoleonic wars a french prisoner
turned soldier
andy's opening lines are quoted directly
from the graphic novels by greg recka
and leandra fernandez this question of
is this it is a hint at their big
problem despite their
immortality they can still die at any
time and they might not even know when
their present wounds might be their
final fatal ones
everyone's still with me now the
prologue here cuts away from andy's
lifeless
space and i'm just so tired of it and it
cuts
right before the moment we later revisit
the scene where her pupils
contract signaling her return to life
since the biological reflex for our
pupils to contract when light shines
directly into them their eyes switch
from dead and dilated
to ready and kill and tight their team
name the old guard is a nod to the us
army's third infantry
the oldest active duty regiment serving
since 1784.
andy gives a gift to booker oh first
edition don quixote mm-hmm
that couldn't have been cheap it wasn't
gervante says don quixote was first
published in 1620
and first editions go for 35 thousand
dollars unlike the
insane first edition of homer's the
iliad casually given a j lo by high
school student the boy next door
this is the first edition i can't accept
this this must have cost a fortune
it was a buck at a garage sale one man's
trash
a first edition of don quixote actually
exists and makes sense as an antiquity
that these immortals would give to each
other
because it's a tale of a delusional
warrior naively fighting to improve the
world
according to old notions of chivalry
much like these mercenaries and he goes
to the trouble of deleting a tourist
selfie that caught her in frame setting
up you know why it's such a defeat when
she ends up on the kill box security
feed later and he detects all the
flavors of the rare baklava
nikki gives her another example of her
age because she's literally spent
thousands of years refining her palate
with flavors from all over the world and
this also sets up andy
having the sharpest sense when they
later try to recollect their dream of
nile she's a marine
her near combat duty
afghanistan they take this south sudan
rescue job from copley and i just love
how smooth this team is
they've clearly done countless jobs like
this joe wipes the guard's blood off his
sword on the guard's pants and then
they toss the gun to each other just
casually they keep moving and you'll
notice throughout the movie they almost
always pick up the ammo from the enemies
they kill before they move on yeah it's
a no-brainer that action movies almost
always fail to do just took that a guy
no time to pick up his ammo
a few moments later ah now but of course
it's all a setup
but they come back to life and the
teamwork between joe and nikki just
great to watch
the moment they wake up they check in
with each other to make sure they're
both packed and then joe
flips the shotgun as nikki shoots out
the guy's leg
dropping the guy just as joe lowers the
shotgun to line up with his face
now andy uses this double-sided axe one
custom made for her by amazon's and note
that in every battle she wields it
she's victorious and she only comes
close to death when she's separated from
this weapon and given the key close-up
on this weapon when she's finally
reunited with it at the end of the movie
there's definitely a spiritual
connection between andy and this blade
so after they recover from the setup joe
says
those shoes were a particularly
grotesque touch he's referring to those
girls shoes that he found piled up
before
as veteran mercenaries they would
recognize piles of shoes as dark signs
outside
infamous historical death camps marine
corporal nile freeman takes a slash to
the neck and visions connect these five
immortals
notice nile's perspective
that last image was underwater this
early in the movie we're seeing how nile
was already detecting quinn
who was still trapped in that iron
casket at the bottom of the sea joe
sketches nile and these close-ups are
actually a cameo by old guard co-creator
liang fernandez these are his hands he's
recreating his graphic novel art
look being left in mystery can be a good
thing for example
not knowing for sure whether someone's
carrying the most discreet front pocket
wallet the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode so the ridge helps you carry
what you need
every day from their flagship ridge
wallet to their portable charging
commuter backpack they want to make the
most out of what you're bringing with
you the ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
or carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design and it's
chainsaw proof so you can go ahead and
pick that fight with a local lumberjack
your cash and cards will be safe
this is their matte cobalt wallet they
have other colors including some very
flashy tiki designs it's light it's
strong
and it's blue the color of her eyes they
make it easy to buy with free shipping
and free returns in a lifetime guarantee
and it's got thirty thousand five star
reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
next we meet pharmaceo steven merrick
played by harry melling aka big d
from the harry potter series his
character's gotta be inspired by
disgraced pharma ceo martin shkreli then
andy starts to explain
i lead a group of immortals an army i
guess
soldiers fighters like you later niall
calls her out
you're an army of four yeah andy used
the word army instead of just
mercenaries to try to ease this marine
into joining their ranks
and he tricks nile by fake killing the
russian pilot
you don't speak russian do you why
because i told the pilot to play dead of
course setting up the whole
russian trick they play on merrick in
the final act do you think he speaks
russian
they arrive at their first safe house
just outside of paris
saskatchewan bill this place has been
abandoned for 50 years
wow
goosenville is directly in the flight
path of charles de gaulle airport and in
1973 there was an
infamous paris air show crash that
killed 14 people and local residents now
say that the passing planes are a
constant reminder of that tragedy so a
lot of people don't want to live there a
flashback shows andy holding
past immortal named lykon during his
death during the conquest of alexander
the great and then a more vivid dream
from nile
reveals quinn quinn and andy found each
other in the second millennia bc
when was wandering the desert dying of
exhaustion again
and again which is pretty tragic
considering her later fate accused of
witchcraft and drowned in an iron coffin
choking on seawater over and over for
500 years
yikes whether it's this or black mirror
netflix just loves to torture souls with
immortality
it's like they're trying to make us want
to die now queen is based on noriko in
the source material
an immortal who is lost at sea and
returned in a later issue
seeking vengeance justice quinn appears
to do in this movie's final scene and
you'll notice interestingly she's
drinking
a glass of water almost as if to show
she is no longer triggered by swallowing
water
and has mastered her fear of death joe
and nikki get taken
and the others regroup in another
hideout where is stash an original
sculpture by
rodan and they joke that andy might have
slept with him and then niall asks
why us that way madness lies
booker is quoting shakespeare's king
lear when lear expresses his grief over
his cruel daughter
but trying to avoid losing himself over
anxiety and king lear also gets quoted
later in this movie by merrick
together we shall do such things what
they are yet i know not but they shall
be the terrors of the earth yeah merrick
is quoting the line from king lear right
before he actually does lose his mind
as he goes into the wood or telling
merrick's coming tragic fall
a little one now in copley's home the
walls are covered in historical
clippings conspiracy thread
that a youtube theorist like me finds to
be very familiar and comforting
yeah andy was convinced that all the
lives they saved didn't matter but
copley has connected that each life
would go on to prevent countless future
deaths
like the old saying he who saves one
life saves the entire world
he mentions how andy's actions prevented
a nuclear disaster in 1978 which might
refer to the three mile island incident
that was 1979 but the second reactor
went online in 1978 but there's also
been
evidence of a number of cases that could
have been chernobyl level events
throughout the ussr in the late 70s
could have been one of those
earlier there was a shot of all of their
faces photoshopped on union soldiers and
old photographs from the civil war in
1864.
here there's other photos showing andy
carrying a wounded soldier in world war
1 in 1915
andy and niall had talked earlier god
doesn't exist
my god does you know there was a time
when i was worshiped as a god
but now the implication could be that
andy herself is like an
incarnation of god or the very least an
angel some divine intervener
working in mysterious ways to keep the
world from descending too much into
despair without herself
seeing her purpose now in this london
establishing shot you can see
someone in the nearby building recording
production with their smartphone no
wonder andy struggles to stay hidden in
this modern world these damn cameras are
everywhere niall frees the others and
they fight their way out at one point
andy runs up to a soldier and blocks the
shot with the axe blade
[Music]
move i assume she learned from wielding
her axe a weapon she will soon be
reunited with
as they plot their big final move what
do you think oslo 67
sao paulo 34 miles with me what happened
in sao paulo in 1934
1834. i love this line but in real human
history there weren't
any notable armed conflicts in sao paulo
in 1834 or in oslo in 1867 or 1967
whatever it was
maybe because they were so covert but uh
from watching the scene the strategy
just seems to be misdirected besieged
enemies to the front door and then
trick them by swinging through the
window and then i guess flipping a guy
over to break his neck
and now that's a sao paulo and then andy
and i'll pull a russian blossom
on merrick the muggle
play dead [ __ ] i love how nile
works in a [ __ ]
on that fall i don't know to me that
kind of looks like a dummy she might be
falling with
just looks a little pale and lifeless
his mouth isn't really moving
seems like big d is dubbing it over
you don't really see it emoted from the
face there and after it all goes down
the riverside pub where they meet gives
a quick shot of that board detailing its
500 year old floor this is the prospect
of whitby
which claims to be london's oldest
riverside tavern also known as the
devil's tavern andy banishes booker from
the group for 100 years but
as we will see in the final scene he
runs into quinn in paris six months
later
setting up both to be on a collision
course with andy much sooner
comment down below with your thoughts on
the old guard and join this discussion
on discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com
new rockstars follow me on instagram at
evoz follow me rockstars and socials and
subscribe to this channel for breakdowns
of everything you love and let us press
f to pay respects for big d
who should have stayed at the top of
those stairs in the penthouse king
cane
[Music]
you